this is the village of kensou in the
isakul region of northern kyrgyzstan
it is the birthplace of the man who so
his critics say has forced his way into
power and the chaos
since a parliamentary election on
october the 4th was cancelled
because of vote rigging allegations
sadhara japarov
is now prime minister and until new
elections are held acting president
three weeks ago he was serving an
11-year jail term for kidnapping
but here and in much of the vast rural
regions of kyrgyzstan
he is loved by many
i believe in saudi because he's faced
many difficulties in his life
he recognizes the problems that worry
ordinary people like us
things like corruption and land that was
sold to neighboring countries
some politicians support him and some do
not but it's meaningless because we
support him
japar of supporters freed him from jail
during post-election protests
as party leaders scrambled for influence
in what appeared to be a power vacuum
japan supporters charged a peaceful
demonstration in bishkek
many supporters of other opposition
groups fled
in rural towns there are memorials
dedicated to kyrgyz who died fighting
for the soviets in world war
ii and statues of historical figures
japarroth who was a member of parliament
10 years ago
is known for his nationalist views
not much has changed in the village
where he was born
since kyrgyzstan's independence after
the breakup of the soviet union 30 years
ago
the men ride horses to herd cattle and
sheep
most of the young have left for the
capital bishkek or joined the estimated
800 000 kyrgyz forced to find work
abroad
i believe everything will be okay i'm
very proud of sadira japarov
he came from us ordinary people i saw
him once and i asked him to be good
not to bring shame on us a man should
only leave good things and memories
behind him
his critics describe him as a thug
somebody who should still be in jail
a threat to the democratic progress this
country has made they say
but the fact of the matter remains that
the new prime minister of japan
has huge respects in the rural areas of
kyrgyzstan
areas that experts say have repeatedly
been ignored
by governments in the past chance
stratfor al jazeera is
cool kyrgyzstan